foreign
ERS at one of the marches that have
erupted in Peru since the impeachment
and imprisonment of ex-president Pedro
Castillo
but those protests are about much more
than one man
many peruvians are angry at their entire
political class ever wanted to show us
why
he invited us back to his neighborhood
this is Buena Vista on the outskirts of
Lima where he lives with his wife
yaldita and their four children
just 40 minutes from the high-rise
buildings and Chic restaurants of the
capital
here there are no sewage pipes no
hospitals no schools no paved roads
there's no running water either this is
the family's system they have to pay for
a water truck which comes once a week to
fill it it's seldom enough
there are days in which their children
can wash and days they can't when
there's no more water we help each other
between Neighbors afterwards I sat down
with ebba in the family home the roost
partly made of tarpaulin one of the
walls is the side of the Hill It's a
Small Monument to the country's gaping
inequality
if it rains this hill could collapse at
any moment it could fall and hurt my
children but what can we do it's the
only home we have
it's obvious that children and their
education are the center of this house
ever Works in construction 12 hours a
day to keep them fed and uniformed
but the nearest school for his son
Stephen is an hour away by a foot motor
taxi and bus
the community is desperate for a local
school they've set aside this land filed
paperwork they say authorities even
agreed to build it they say that was
five years ago the plot still looks like
this
the politicians come just to get our
vote they say we're going to get you
water a health clinic and it never
happens nothing happens look at our
community this is the reality for so
many peruvians who have gone out to
March
a quarter of peruvians live in poverty
the same pleasing complaints play out in
a multitude of shanty towns and
forgotten rural villages
why do you think the politicians haven't
answered the call for hospitals for
schools for the things that you need
here
because those who govern us have always
been corrupt they start project and hold
them up for years to complete them
inflating the budget they've always done
it we have resources but they take them
and the people are left forgotten that's
why they're angry
darang is still spilling out onto the
streets in a nation that's felt let down
by their politicians for too long john
Holman Al Jazeera Lima